he's taught McShea ESPN NFL Draft and
college football analyst who joins us on
the program good morning Todd how are
you I'm doing well how's it going bud
well I'm excited we're we're fired up we
you know we got the heart well no your
mock draft okay yeah but you don't sound
excited about your mock draft okay what
goes into compiling the mock draft oh
good question
I start in May May and June I spend
evaluating play or watching tape then
start the rankings and then and through
the season get to that point and then
you know the last couple weeks start
looking at all right what our team's
need you know what who obviously what's
the draft order and then and then one of
the teams need and then try to put the
pieces together like a puzzle and it's
easier now because people can't
scrutinize me or don't scrutinize me as
much as they do in about three months
from now but are you factoring in also
what you think the teams will do and
your opinion of what they'll do or is
this just based off need this is what I
think they're going to do it's a little
bit of both
honestly it's a little bit about the
closer I get to the draft and I start
calling teams I'm not going to bother a
GM right now with hey what are you
thinking we're you know are you looking
and those sorts of things but I think
it's fairly obvious like this the
Bengals are they need a quarterback but
they're they have a tough decision to
make if they take chase young the Ohio
State defensive end over Joe burrow at
the quarterback position so those sorts
of things kind of play out throughout
the process okay let me ask you this
then if you're the Bengals if you're
running the Bengals do you take Jill
burrow or chase young this is a brutal
question and I'm going to give you the
honest answer I would take chase young
and it's almost never that I would say
that I you look at the last the last two
years for example they're what I think
eight quarterbacks overtaking in the
first round I think
two of them that you feel great about
that are going to be really good
starters in the league for a long long
time
case young would it would be one of the
biggest shocks of my scouting career 20
years if he didn't turn out to be a very
very high-end player and the
quarterbacks are at best they're like 40
60 in terms of how they turn out now I
know how important they are but the
second most important position and in
scouting and evaluating is finding the
guy that can get after the quarterback
and if I know I can have somebody who's
as good if not better than the BOCES in
chase young I just I would have to go in
that direction and I it goes against
what I normally would say but I I just
think the chase young is that special if
Trevor Lawrence was available this year
Trevor oh okay yeah just being honest so
you would take Trevor Lawrence over
jobber oh yes
yeah and I would take - uh over Joe
Burrell
if - oh was it didn't have the hip
injury now I and I love what Joe's done
but it's been one year and last year
that coming into this season I had a
fourth fifth round great on him no and
you know I've met with him I've talked
to him he's a different cat but like in
a good way he he was just very average
last year and this year he's been
sensational so you just you have to make
sure if you're gonna draft him that you
have a Joe Brady it's going to bring the
best out of him I love his pocket
presence
I think he's as good as you're gonna
find in the college game in terms of
just feeling like the outside rush and
climbing the ladder the inside rush
sidestepping it eyes are always on the
same plane accurate on time everything
that you look for but it's it's just one
year and so there's a little bit of
concern with that but again it
Cincinnati takes him but one overall I
wouldn't have an issue with it at all I
just I just think chase young is more
like he's one of those decade type
players at the defensive end position
yeah I'm there with you
and I would probably look at keeping
Andy Dalton for another year I don't
think Andy Dalton is you know the the
demise of the Bengals I think that the
the Bengals are the demise of the
Bengals and you know Dalton to me is is
still a decent band-aid quarterback
right now he's still what in his early
30s so I might do that if I was gonna
take chase Young I know what I'm getting
with chase young i I'm right there with
you you know it's like Bo so I feel like
I know what I'm getting there's always
that possibility of I did miss out on my
franchise quarterback and you know
Cincinnati would have to roll the dice
on that we say that every year and you
know Lamar Jackson was the fifth quarter
I've taken in that amazing group yeah
and now he's having the year that he's
having and maybe it won't and at the end
of last season no one thought that he
was going to be the guy that he is this
year and so the quarterbacks I mean
they're there it's the hardest position
to evaluate in sports I'm convinced of
it you because we think we now know what
the criteria we now know what you know
it takes to play that position when I
watch Lamar Jackson at Louisville I just
know that he had a great offensive mind
with Bobby Petrino he could he could he
could do what he needed to do when he
needed to do it and then the knock was
well but he's playing at Louisville ok
and then it was well but he's more of a
runner than a passer ok we get caught up
in how does he look in the pocket
remember Tyler Murray I wouldn't take I
said I would take in number one I you
know and I think he's had a pretty good
year and probably lived up to the number
one pick I don't know but we get caught
up in these are the negatives I want to
know what your positives are and then
how do I build on that I want to take
Cam Newton so we can be Cam Newton I
want to take Lamar Jackson so he can be
Lamar Jackson we tend to put them into
our system you've got to be this guy in
this system and I think that's where a
lot of these teams make mistakes this is
the thing that I've learned the most
probably in the last three years is it's
weekend it doesn't take a super Scout to
figure out that Lamar Jackson's as
phenomenal athlete and it can be a
really good player it doesn't take
super Scout to figure out the Sam dorms
really talented but the issue is always
when they get to the NFL who are they
paired up with who's coaching them and
look even if you go back and talk to
John Harbaugh and the difference from
year one to year two with Lamar and that
would not spend the whole thing they
realize you know we can't do it our way
let's do it his way him and his boy may
work and it has worked and the same
thing with Bill O'Brien and deshaun
Watson listen like they change the
verbage make it faster let's get quicker
the NFL is is trickling up I guess if if
you will from the college level and like
the college game it's becoming the NFL
game and NFL coaches are having to
figure out we can't do it the old way
you know it's we don't the Eli Manning's
unfortunately is phenomenal as he was
and the Super Bowls and everything else
like that's not going to work for very
long
we need a mobile quarterback we need to
play fast we need to play different it's
a different game now and I think you're
seeing that in terms of the evaluation
process as well he's Todd McShea ESPN
NFL draft analyst more questions about
tua or Justin Herbert well to to is I
don't want to say simple but to is a you
make the football evaluation and then
you have to rely on the medical and it's
so frustrating because he's such a good
player and I don't know if you've spent
any time with him yeah he is he's an
even better dude I mean it this guy he
loves the game he does everything the
right way he loves his family it's it is
just everything that you want in a son
if you will but now you got to ankle
injuries you've got a knee injury and
most importantly the hip injury and he's
not gonna be able to walk for almost two
and a half more months so you just don't
know it it's going to start with the
combine medical and then it'll be the
combine recheck which is usually the
first week in April and then every team
that has any interest in them in the
first 15 20 picks is going to send their
whole medical staff out there and
evaluate them but I think from a
football standpoint he would be the
first overall pick in this dress the
Bengals would take that would be my my
opinion if he was healthy if he was
completely healthy
but it just it really comes down to
where he is not only for year one in
terms of like the recovery but is this
something and I've heard different
stories from different medical people
but is is this something that's going to
be regraded
and become a career problem where three
four years down the road we you know we
lost the guy that we spent the number
one overall pick on so that that that
one's trickier Justin Herbert is is more
of a he's the football evaluation is the
tough part because he's big he's strong
he can run he has a big-time arm he's a
lot like Josh Allen with the bills when
when Josh was coming out of Wyoming
he's very smart but he's very
introverted he's kind of the opposite of
what you think of when a quarterback
walks into the room and I think NFL
teams are going to struggle with that
any other quarterbacks
dipping into the top or first round
Jake's prom is the smartest quarterback
I've been around a long time the Georgia
quarterback he has physical limitations
but he he's a type of guy that overcomes
it Jacob Eason needs another year he was
the well he was the starter and then and
then he got injured and from beat him
out of Georgia and then he transferred
to Washington
Ethan probably if he decides to come out
early he's the most physically gifted
quarterback in this class in terms of
just pure arm talent but I really think
he needs another year or Washington
aside from Cincinnati in Miami who will
definitely draft a quarterback who
definitely the Lions could you know
they're sitting right now at like five
that range Jacksonville I wouldn't rule
out Carolina
yeah what's Carolina gonna do with where
the charge is going to do what's going
on
with Jon Gruden and in car there are a
lot of teams that are they're
interesting this year more so than
normal that's like the last few years
we've had more record of accident we've
had teams in the top ten have needed
them I think I think the Broncos are
happy with what they have but you never
know just going down the Raiders pick
again at 16 the Buccaneers are they are
they happy with Jameis even though he's
you know he's played well recently but
what you defector in Teddy Bridgewater
and Cam Newton where they end up if they
end up with another team and then how
that affects the draft no question but I
the point is in the first
1618 pics there are about eight or nine
teams that potentially could have
interest in quarterbacks its Washington
sold on to Wayne Haskins well the owner
I know is but but but if I'm a coach the
coach you get has got to be sold on him
as well or he's not taking that job so I
I've been holding back from calling
Irvin this week wondering what what he
was doing in the box I it's the current
structure I can't I couldn't allow a
friend to take the job without saying
something now if you get a new general
manager wait wait are you are you the
friend urban to tell him not to take
this job I'm just saying hypothetically
[Laughter]
I would make the phone call and say make
sure you get a football guy who's in
between the owner and you and and and
you can completely run the football
stuff you can make the decisions I mean
that that's the issue right now under
the current
struck if washington can't succeed they
need daniel snyder to take a step back
they need to hire a general manager that
knows football and can evaluate players
and then they need a coach who can you
know take those players and develop them
would you rather coach Washington or
Dallas Dallas yeah yeah between those
two I'd rather coach Carolina I think
that I would Dallas but you know I just
any team in 31 other teams don't
sugarcoat it I won't okay hey Todd great
to talk to you and Merry Christmas and
thanks for the mock draft all right
that's Todd McShea ESPN NFL draft
analyst there for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]